breaking news this morning Donald
Trump's poll numbers were getting a
little too high so the Biden
Administration is indicting him again
this one is different though this time
they are not indicting Trump over his
souvenir boxes from the White House or
over an in-kind campaign contribution
that he made to himself or over some
crazy lady who fantasized about him
ravishing her in Bergdorf Goodman's this
time the feds are bringing out the big
guns they're indicting Trump over his
role in
January 6th the worst day in the history
of this or any Republic
has responded to the indictment with
characteristic a plum truthing
tweeted he truth it wow
all caps wow on Sunday night while I was
with my family having just arrived from
the Turning Point event in Florida where
I saw the straw where I won the straw
poll against all other Republican
candidates with 85.7 percent with all
polls showing me leading in the
Republican primary by very substantial
numbers almost everyone predicting that
I will be the Republican nominee for
president what a parenthetical Trump the
king of parentheticals
uh and as I am leading Democrat Joe
Biden in the polls by a lot horrifying
news for our country was given to me by
my attorneys deranged Jack Smith the
prosecutor with Joe Biden's doj sent a
letter
parentheses again it was Sunday night
stating that I am a target of the
January 6th grand jury investigation and
giving me a very short four days to
report to the grand jury which almost
always means an arrest and indictment
then it goes on I actually only read
a small portion of this of this truth
statement uh it's great strongly
encourage you to go read the whole thing
it's at the very least quite
entertaining so now we wait
not only on this indictment
but on the next one
and the one after that
and the one after that and the dozens
and dozens that the Democrats have
prepared for Trump until he breathes his
last breath after which they will dig up
his corpse and indict him again I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
quite a lot to get to today not just in
the Republican primary but in the
Democrat primary you've now got the
White House referring to the biggest
threat to Joe Biden in the Democrat
Party that would be Bobby Kennedy Jr
calling him vile we'll get to that in
just a moment first though of all the
crazy indictments and investigations and
accusations against Trump this one is
the craziest one this one is the least
defensible this is less defensible than
the Russia hoax this is less defensible
than the Ukraine hoax this is less
defensible than the supposed porn star
payment which is just an in-kind
contribution to his own Campaign which
is not a crime at all it's totally
acceptable uh this is crazier even than
the Bergdorf Goodman lady that gossip
columnist who kept on inventing news
stories about how Trump ravished her in
a department store this one is crazier
because
Trump's actions on January 6th whatever
you think of them you might think they
were irresponsible you might think they
were stupid you might think they were
self-defeating you might think they were
immoral even
they're not without precedent in
American history and when it comes to
politics they're more Justified than
many other Trump actions
because there were legitimate questions
about the 2020 election and if you ask
me there remain legitimate questions
it's quite clear that the Democrats
changed the voting rules in the run-up
to the election in order to disadvantage
Donald Trump in some cases they did so
in contravention of the law and
contravention of state constitutions as
in the case of Pennsylvania it was a
hotly contested election if the very
fact that the voting numbers were so
radically different from any election
that we had seen before it right people
people say Joe Biden won with 81 million
votes well that's I think that's 10
million more votes than the the last
highest number how on Earth did we get
to that well because
in this election we had widespread
mail-in voting we had widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots sent out we
had widespread ballot harvesting we had
all sorts of things that you hadn't seen
previously so there were all sorts of
questions about the election the last
time we saw an election that was this
hotly contested was 1876.
what happened in 1876 that was the
election between Rutherford B Hayes the
Republican and Sam Tilden the Democrat
and there were all sorts of questions
about the election and whether or not
every ballot that was cast was legit in
some cases people were prevented from
having their ballots counted in in the
case of 2020 we're talking about ballots
stuffed in Lockers in Michigan we're
talking about pipes bursting during the
vote count vote count that dragged on
for days and days and weeks and weeks in
the case of 1876 we're talking about
people being turned away at the polls
we're talking about political violence
at the polls in any case you had this
debate
people insisted that Sam Tilden won Sam
Tilden I think incontrovertibly
outpelled Rutherford B Hayes at the
popular vote level though that doesn't
necessarily matter but
Rutherford B Hayes
was holding on to the count by one vote
so what did they do they did something
not totally dissimilar from what you saw
on January 6th the worst day ever which
is they held up the vote count and then
in in 1876 unlike in 2020 the the
Republicans and the Democrats went into
a back room struck a deal this was
called the compromise the bargain of of
1876 and they said okay
we'll give the Republicans the
presidency but the Republicans need to
pull out of the South for reconstruction
and that was a deal acceptable to both
parties where do you find that method in
the Constitution where do you find that
method in U.S code you don't it was just
a deal struck because you were in this
this really hot moment that didn't seem
to be accommodated for
in the law a similar thing went on in
2020 we'd never seen a global pandemic
that changed all the voting rules that
shut down the vote counts that created
widespread mail-in ballots it was after
you had the Deep state after you had the
political apparatics for the opposing
Party come in and for four years
consistently try to illegally undermine
the sitting president uh we didn't have
that kind of deal so anyway Trump held
his rally it didn't work out obviously
it didn't work out as a matter of
maintaining the presidency it didn't
work out as a matter of political Optics
but to suggest that that is somehow an
egregious unprecedented totally
politically unheard of uh thing to do is
just crazy and the Democrats now because
they won
optically because they won practically
in terms of holding the White House they
are never going to stop punishing this
guy and it's and it's always about
January 6 because what it's really
always about is the fact that Trump won
in the first place which he wasn't
supposed to do and they rigged the 2016
election using the doj and the FBI to
rig it against him he somehow
miraculously squeaked through and
they're they're never going to forgive
him for that and they're never going to
let up
so our political order gets a little
wonkier and when when things go out of
whack in the political order you're
probably going to want to have some
tangible assets you're probably going to
want to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days
away from the Durbin Accords the
greatest threat to the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years
on August 22nd brics Nations as Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa are
expected to announce
the launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the U.S and
the dollar is cornerstones of the Global
Financial system
how can you protect your IRA or 401k
from The Fallout from this Landmark
announcement now is the time to
diversify with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty that would
be right now when currencies fail gold
is a safe haven how much more time does
the Dollar have protect your savings
with gold Birch gold has an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers
98 98 98 get your free info kit on gold
if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend on again text
nulls Canada wlas to 98.98 98. the
number two guy in the Republican race
Ron DeSantis responded
on the fly to this news that Trump is
being indicted yet again by the Biden
Administration here's his answer
I think what we've seen in this country
is an attempt to criminalize politics
and to try to criminalize differences so
I don't know what was all about that but
I but I do know that we look at
institutions unfortunately like our own
FBI and Department of Justice and we've
seen the politicization of those
institutions we've seen them be
weaponized against Americans uh pro-life
activists can have the SWAT Team come
out of meanwhile Hunter Biden he would
have been in jail if he were a
Republican and we all know that so so
that's I think been a frustration to see
uh how that is wielded so I can't speak
about that because I haven't seen it but
I can tell you one of my jobs as
president will be to end the
weaponization of these agencies and I
will get that job done we will make it
happen
this is a good answer
he's in an impossible spot and he gave a
good answer and the best part of the
answer is that first part of it when he
says they're trying to criminalize
politics
they're trying to say that now if you
dispute the results of an election
something that they have done without
justification for decades if you with
great justification in an election where
they changed all the rules right away if
if you dispute that you're committing a
treasonous act and you need to be put
away forever and we're going to get you
six ways from Sunday and he's saying
that if if you disagree now with some
fashionable new ideology that's cropped
up you know the kind that we're not
allowed to talk about on big Tech that
you're committing a crime against
humanity you need to be censored you
need to be ostracized you need to be
kicked out of society he's saying this
is a big problem and it's not just about
Trump you're seeing the FBI show up and
surveil Catholic masses you're seeing
parents described as domestic terrorists
you're seeing pro-lifers have their
doors kicked in almost and have their
seven kids watch daddy get arrested
because he he opposes abortion and
infanticide it's the criminalization of
ordinary reasonable political disputes
really perfectly good answer and yet
it's not a good answer for DeSantis
because no matter how he answers this
thing Trump is the center of attention
and this is always the uphill slog for
DeSantis it's why I've said from the
beginning DeSantis is a smart guy I like
him personally I don't know him very
well but in as much as I do know in
person I think he's a really great guy I
think he's been a terrific governor of
Florida I think he very likely could be
a very good president the uphill slog
for him here is the election is about
Trump
and sometimes you'll hear people on the
right they'll say well do we really want
this election to be about Trump well I
don't really care what you want it just
is because in war and in politics your
enemy has a say and the enemy and the
opponents are making this about Donald
Trump they're going to indict him they
are indicting him it's happening right
now and so it is about him are we going
to allow the leader of the opposition
to be just indicted and thrown in prison
in America oh we're not then I guess we
have to defend him if we're going to
defend him then the election's about him
and you might pull your hair out you
might say but it's not fair and it's not
right and it's not how it should be well
okay sorry you know that's politics man
you you don't get to set all of the
rules that that's that's one of the real
tricks of politics and war is you've got
to respond with Prudence to the
circumstances that are sometimes
affected by the moves that your
opponents make as well it's a really
tricky spot so how can DeSantis thread
it he's threading it as well as he
possibly can now but
even making every smart move in it
saying every smart thing and writing
just about every smart policy
Trump remains dominant in the polls and
this indictment is going to probably
boost him up in the polls even more
think about all the great stuff that
DeSantis has done I'm just I'm just
adding to the tragedy of of what and
when I say political tragedy I don't I
don't just mean something that's sort of
unfortunate or or disadvantageous or
something like that I mean
that the seeds of Destruction were built
in from the beginning I mean a tragedy
in The Shakespearean sense I mean
tragedy in the classical sense here
here's another great great thing that
came out of DeSantis DeSantis you know
has been going after the woke School
administrators and so this is Florida
state board that is allied with Governor
DeSantis and it just blocked the
appointment of a university president at
Florida Atlantic University Florida
Atlantic University wanted to hire this
woke Navy guy who's got a long history
of supporting woke politics and and all
sorts of crazy liberalism the the board
shut down the appointment of that
potential University presidency you're
seeing not only the right political
vision
but you're seeing people wielding that
political power
in real time actually getting stuff done
man
isn't that great
and yet
you're not seeing DeSantis get any
credit for that in the polls and very
likely you won't at least unless
something radically
changes in the election so a lot of
people are saying all right if this is
among the DeSantis supporters they'll
say if DeSantis isn't going to be the
president
maybe he could be the VP pick but I
think we all know that's not going to
happen these are two top dogs these guys
are not playing nicely with one another
they are going Head to Head
the primary is going to get even more
bruising as things go on and so Trump's
not going to pick DeSantis to be VP and
DeSantis probably wouldn't want to be
Trump's VP
these guys are both going for the top
job so where does that leave us I've got
one crazy suggestion
DeSantis could still be the the GOP
nominee I'm not saying it couldn't
happen he's still got a decent enough
shot at it
Trump might get indicted I don't know
Trump might God forbid fall down the
stairs or something so he might he might
fall away as the number one guy but if
things keep up as they are and Trump is
the nominee and if Trump somehow manages
to make it through and become the
president again
what if DeSantis were the chief of staff
it seems crazy I know you said why would
Rhonda Sanders want to be the chief of
staff well because DeSantis is clearly a
policy wonk DeSantis is clearly good at
pulling the levers of power getting
things done sometimes behind the scenes
these are things that Trump is not
necessarily interested in Trump is a
world historic figure Trump likes the
big picture Trump likes the cameras
Trump likes talking Trump doesn't always
like the the details and the minutia of
the Personnel decisions Trump doesn't
always like the details in minutia of
the policy decisions and so what if you
had a president Trump and a white house
chief of staff Rhonda Santos white house
chief of staff in many ways is the most
powerful person in the world
most powerful person in Washington and
therefore in the whole world
working on all this little Personnel the
minutia the policy it's not unheard of
we've had Governors who have served as
white house chief of staff before
including after they were Governor uh
Sherman Adams was the chief of staff to
Eisenhower he was a governor of New
Hampshire John Cena for George H.W bush
he was governor of New Hampshire then he
became white house chief of staff I'm
just throwing this out there as a
possible
outcome because a lot of people are
saying well look Trump is today likely
going to be the nominee and I I would
support Trump and probably the people
who are supporting DeSantis now would
come over and vote for Trump again it's
not totally clear that people who would
vote for Trump would vote for DeSantis
and so okay let's say it's going to be
Trump let's just say it let's just let's
just go with that hypothetical you don't
want to lose DeSantis DeSantis is a
really great political Talent what could
you do is is there any way for these two
guys to work together that's just my
suggestion I'm throwing it out there
campaigns take it for what it's worth
now speaking of a potential Trump
Administration New York Times is
reporting terrified horrified
that if Trump did manage to make it into
office again
he wants to expand
the powers of the president here we go
generally Simo Donald trumpo here we go
the authoritarian autocratic fascist he
wants to expand presidential Powers the
time says
the exciting campaign policy proposals
and interviews of people close to Trump
Trump wants to bring independent
agencies like the FCC the FTC the
Communications Commission the Trade
Commission under direct presidential
control take away some of their
independence
wants to revive the practice of
impounding funds meaning to refuse to
spend money that Congress has
appropriated for certain programs and
supposedly independent agencies and he
he wants to make the presidency really
strong and powerful again and
if this proposal came out 10 years ago
If This Were an Obama proposal you know
all of the Republicans and especially
the conservative Republicans the Tea
Party types
they would be throwing a fit about this
they say no we want less Presidential
Power that was for much of my lifetime
that was what the Republicans said they
wanted we want less Presidential Power
now the conservatives are saying we want
more Presidential Power what changed
well one the Libertarians have lost some
of their sway at the elite levels of the
GOP
and the traditional conservatives have
gained more sway the populists have
gained more sway as well but also people
have have
seen what it looks like to give up this
power
for much of my life
so and don't forget I'm a pretty young
man I'm fresh and beer Island young so
before I was even a glint in my father's
eye Republicans were much more confident
wielding power Republicans were much
much less under the sway of the
libertarian Notions of just giving up
all the government power but for much of
my lifetime we said no we just want to
give up power we don't want the
president to have a lot we want a very
weak president well okay what does a
weak president mean it doesn't mean that
power goes away
a weak president means that the power
goes elsewhere where's the power going
to go is it going to go to Congress no
Congress doesn't want power at all
Congress doesn't want responsibility
that's why Congress gave away its power
to the independent agencies
so where does the power go the power
goes to the bureaucracy
and the power goes to bureaucratic
agencies specifically that don't have a
lot of presidential supervision so it's
not as though the president gives up
power and then all of a sudden the
people get more power whether through
their elected representatives or the
appointees of the president no the
president gives up power and it just
goes to completely unaccountable
unelected bureaucrats who are
overwhelmingly liberal who cannot really
be brought under any particular control
and who have a bad vision of the country
so what the populists have realized is
something that the traditional
conservatives have long understood and
it's something that the GOP is finally
beginning to deal with which is
the power is going to go somewhere
do you want the power to to go to the
bureaucrats there are many worse places
for power to go
then to the U.S president
and this is a trend by the way that
you're seeing not just in the United
States but all around
the world
now when you want to travel all around
the world how do you do it sometimes
you're going to take a car that's why
you got to check out carzing right now
head on over to carson.com Knowles
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for anyone especially if
you're a first-time buyer or have no
credit before you walk into a dealership
and spend the entire day with the
crowd's stress and potential to it not
even find the right car you got to check
out Carson carzing is completely
changing the way you buy a car online
by partnering with Credit Agencies
lenders and over 25 000 dealers
Nationwide
coursing provides you with everything
you need before stepping foot onto a
dealership
once you find the right car for your
ideal budget all you've got to do is
bring your saved deal voucher with you
to the dealership to finalize your next
ride super simple even if you're not in
the market for a new car you should
check out Carson anyway coursing's
online window shopping experience goes
beyond mirror images you dive deep into
each vehicle's specifications features
and performance capabilities
zoom in on the craftsmanship of the
Interior Marvel at The Cutting Edge
technology check out all the great stuff
about these cars carsing helps make your
experience faster cheaper less stressful
go to carzing.com Knowles today find the
best deals near you that is carzing.com
Knowles
serendipitous timing with this new
indictment of President Trump because it
all surrounds January 6 the end
who was the face of January 6th we we
you know you remember there's one face
that sums up January 6 and it's the man
in the red white and blue face paint
with the Furs shirtless and the horn hat
on that's he is Mr January 6th and
coincidentally
that guy just got out of prison
got out of his halfway house
which he went to after prison
and he has sat down for his first long
sit-down in-person interview
and he happened to do that with yours
truly with your favorite podcaster that
man's name is Jacob chansley you
remember him the horn hat guy the
insurrectionist the Q Anon Shaman well
after January 6th the worst day in the
history of our sacred democracy Jacob
was thrown in jail for over two years I
sat down with him
here's a little teaser of what we talked
about
you were in solitary confinement for ten
and a half months ten and a half months
that seems like torture I experienced
some miraculous things in solitary I'm
freaking out I'm gonna sell I'm freaking
out I'm like what the hell and I had a
Bible in my hand I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna close my eyes and I'm gonna open
this Bible and I'm going to point to a
random verse with my eyes closed and I
need you to speak with me so I close my
eyes I opened the Bible I point to a
random verse and the verse was I am
yours and you are mine I have redeemed
you and called you by name O Jacob
oh yeah
[Music]
the full
version of this episode
cleaned up you know we cleaned up the
audio a little bit this the full I think
it's like two hours or two and a half
hours of this episode we'll be on the
Michael Knowles Show YouTube channel and
it's coming out soon I think it's
actually coming out later today now this
is the the version that will be cleaned
up for YouTube we had to take certain
things out or the whole episode would go
down on YouTube if you want to catch the
completely un uncensored raw we talk
about everything version then you've got
to do that on the Michael Knowles Show
podcast feed on RSS and on the Twitter
page at M Knolls show they're going to
be some extra conversations in there
that YouTube will not allow so go check
out that long interview it's coming up
later today
this movement
for populism this movement for greater
representation of the people this
movement for more of a mixed regime in
keeping with the classical conservative
tradition that is not just happening in
America it's happening all over the
world Spain right now
might have its first properly right-wing
government since Francisco Franco
this Coalition involves not just the
center-right party
that's been prominent in Spain for a
while but also the populist right-wing
party that would be the Vox party voice
according to the Associated Press so
it's a left-wing Outlet take it with a
grain of salt but according to
dissociated press the Vox party
Manifesto is virtually quote a copy and
paste of the tenets of the Franco regime
the Franco regime was the right-wing
regime that that beat out the Communists
from taking over Spain and stopped the
Communists from murdering priests and
raping nuns one of the most wicked evil
political movements we've seen in modern
history those Spanish Communists Franco
comes in beats the Communists restores
basic order to Spain though he wasn't
authoritarian ruler and uh but he wasn't
he wasn't a totalitarian he wasn't some
terrible awful rotten guy he he beat the
terrible awful rotten guys the
Communists and he maintained power until
the 70s after that Spain democratized a
little bit but what happens uh so often
in the name of democracy you just see
this imposition of ever more liberal
government with less representation of
the people less respect for traditions
and upending of the society that most
people want and so now you're seeing a
return of more of a right-wing party
it's a reminder that right-wing populism
is popular Trump did not just
accidentally win
that this is how the Liberals around the
West want to write the story of the 2016
election oh Trump only won Trump just
won because Hillary was particularly
unpopular it was a total fluke that's
the only reason that guy managed to
sweep by is because Hillary was uniquely
unpopular
okay sure
then how do you explain brexit
how do you explain
brexit
an expression of the same popular
right-wing sentiments in the UK that we
saw in the 2016 election here at pretty
much exactly the same time how do you
explain
well the brexit you see it was because
of dishonest right-wing propaganda
campaign it was a total fluke wasn't
supposed to happen Okay brexit was a
fluke how do you explain the election
and popularity of the right-wing
government of Victor or ban in Hungary
well I was that was also that was just a
fluke okay how do you explain the
victory of Georgia Maloney who at the
very least campaigned as a right-wing
populist leader in Italy well I don't
know that was also a fluke how do you
explain the election of right-wing
governments in Sweden how do you explain
well that was also okay all right I
guess it's all wow it's all a fluke
so all just an accident because of these
particular circumstances
that's been happening at exactly the
same time throughout the West I don't
think it's a flute guys
I think this is a civilization-wide
phenomenon because of a too long
experiment in liberalism that often in
the name of democracy has undermines
democracy and more important than that
has undermined the pillars of our
foundation the things that we all really
value family order Justice culture
Beauty truth we're not even allowed to
speak the truth on some of the biggest
communication Platforms in the world
right now we're not even allowed to
speak the truth when we go to our
schools when we go to our jobs in the
government
we're not allowed to question the ever
more capricious and corrupt leaders of
our of our liberal governments
it's a civilization-wide phenomenon to
say wow whenever we threw out tradition
in the name of some bright Progressive
Utopia we threw out the baby with the
bath water I'm not even sure we threw
out the bathwater I think we might have
just thrown out the baby and so the West
is waking up now
the people very clearly are on the side
of
tradition on the side of order on the
side of just being normal okay
the question is do the people have
sufficient political power to overcome
the liberal regime in 2016 we did so not
for very long in the brexit the people
did although the liberal regime was able
to really water down that brexit and gum
up the works for a long time in Hungary
actually has fared pretty well in Italy
not so much Brussels has reimposed a lot
of its will even on a popular right wing
so this is a live political issue but
you can't look at the 2024 presidential
race in America outside of that issue
when people say gosh why can't we just
go back and have a a kind of early 2000
style Republican candidate like Mike
Pence why can't we just go back and have
a kind of
1990s 2000 style Republican candidate
like ASA Hutchinson or Chris Christie
even Chris Christie frankly is even kind
of Hip To The Jive for that sort of
stuff or like I don't know Tim Scott or
somebody like that why can't we do that
because that's not the time we're in
that's not what's motivating right-wing
politics it is not a cult of personality
around Trump as the Liberals and the
never trumpers want to pretend that it
is this is a broad movement throughout
the entire West and you can deny that if
you're an establishment and a squishy
lib type you can deny that all you like
but it will be to your own detriment
because this phenomenon is not going
anywhere now speaking of Chris Christie
speaking of politics overseas Chris
Christie did not show up to the Tucker
Carlson Blaze media
candidate forum last week
Trump didn't show up Christy didn't show
up the other candidates did some of them
did very well Ron DeSantis did very well
Nikki Haley actually did pretty well
some of the candidates did very poorly
Mike Pence didn't didn't fare very well
there ASA Hutchinson got completely
obliterated but Christy now
[Music]
he is
playing armchair quarterback Chris
Christie is trying to play a little
catch-up here and he's he's going on
television to say what he would have
said
had he shown up to face Tucker's
questions
in Iowa you weren't at the Tucker
Carlson uh Forum but if you were being
pressed on Ukraine like that how would
you have responded I would have said
you've always been wrong about this
Tucker and you're still wrong that in
fact what's going on George is that this
is a proxy war with China
the Chinese are funding the Russian war
by buying Russian oil they're
coordinating with the Iranians to
provide lethal weapons uh to the Russian
army and we could decide when to have
this conflict right now the ukrainians
are willing to fight this fight for
themselves if they have our support to
be able to win it if the Chinese watch
us back away from Ukraine as Tucker
Carlson and others would Advocate
believe me the next move will be Taiwan
yeah it's what he would have said and
boy that would have played really really
well can you imagine had
had it been the case that Chris Christie
had shown up on Friday and actually
faced her oh man that would have been
something else this is just a real life
expression of the Family Guy bit about
Italians speaking in the hypothetical
oh being confident like an Italian guy
in any given theoretical situation if
that was me I'm just saying if that was
me they are lucky that was not me
because if the circumstances were such
as you have described them but with me
in them that's a very different and
scary outcome for those involved if
to a t not just describing Chris
Christie but a broader subset of the
Italian-American culture this is maybe
some of you didn't grow up with Children
of the metro jordano in your communities
but this is exactly how Italian
Americans talk especially now listen
here had I've been there that night oh
I need to prove any of this uh
practically because I'm not gonna I was
it wasn't there but had I been there oh
boy and that's totally right and that's
what Christie's doing well the question
is all right Christy if you're so
confident if you got such a good answer
why didn't you show up you didn't show
up because you feared that Tucker was
going to obliterate you which he would
have done
and I'm not even making this observation
as a criticism of Christie I'm actually
paying a compliment to Christie
Christie's a smart politician
Christy knew that he had basically
nothing to gain by showing up for a
one-on-one with Tucker Carlson and he
had a considerable amount to lose
Christie is a smart politician I have
long predicted that he could have a
moment in this race especially if Ron
DeSantis is unseated as the number two
guy
and so
we all we all wait on the chrysosons
the croissants and for now
Christy's going to back away he's going
to give up the opportunity to make gains
in the polls which
in Iowa with Tucker I don't think even
really existed
and he's going to preserve his three
percent and he's not gonna he's not
gonna lose his support as we saw
happened with Asa Hutchinson and Mike
Pence both of them took that risk with I
don't think a lot of potential upside
and they got absolutely crushed
but this is the issue this is this is
then the other issue for Christy
he's playing it safe and when you get
three percent you play it safe You're
Gonna Lose
now he might be trying to play it safe
while the other candidates play risky so
that he can gain their support and just
steadily increase in the polls the
problem is
and Mike Pence aside
all the big players are playing it safe
Ron DeSantis is playing it safe
Donald Trump is certainly playing it
safe that's why Trump didn't show up in
Iowa
because what did Trump have to gain
maybe he could have taken a little bit
of support Tucker kind of likes Trump
but you remember during the Dominion
lawsuit you had those texts come out
from Tucker that showed that Tucker was
really frustrated with Trump and he he
criticized Trump on some occasion and
Tucker is known for just going after
anybody that he's interviewing just
about and so I think Trump made the
calculation all right I don't have a lot
to gain and I potentially could lose
part of my 30-point lead right now so
I'm just not going to show up I'm going
to play it safe Ron DeSantis broadly
speaking is playing it safe in this race
he's running as As Trump 2.0 I'm I'm
like Trump I've got all the good
qualities of trump but I'm gonna I'm
gonna Implement policies a little bit
better I'm not going to step too far out
on any of these contentious policy areas
you see this especially in Ukraine
Rhonda said this is trying to straddle
this line on Ukraine well I I want to
pull some funding but I don't want to
totally back out of of our support for
the war and he's just he's just playing
it safe I get it he's the number two guy
but you know what happens to the number
two guy when the number two guy plays it
safe the whole time he comes in at
number two
when the number two guy plays it safe
for the whole campaign he's going to be
the best
loser
and that is doubly triply quadruply true
of the number three guy and the number
four guy the number five guy you know
the one candidate who's not really
playing it safe right now is Vivek
ramaswamy and Vivek ramaswamy went from
zero percent nobody ever heard the guy's
name to now number three and who knows
he's even making some threats at
becoming the number two guy in the race
this is a businessman never held public
office he's like 12 years old you know
the Vegas is 37 years old he's got a
name that is not particularly well known
in American politics he's got this
Indian name he's a Hindu he's he's come
out of completely out of left field but
because he's taking risks and he's
speaking openly and he's addressing
issues in a way where he doesn't back
away some woman comes up and starts
yelling at him during his campaign event
he says Hey give her the microphone
let's talk let's have a debate he's
really putting himself out there
and he's doing
very well if any candidates want to take
on the big guy
if they want to upset a race it seems to
be pretty solidly locked in with the
number one guy at a 30 point Advantage
they're gonna have to play it a little
bit less safe
but nobody wants to be the first one to
do it and so what you're seeing is maybe
what ended up happening in 2016 which is
everyone just kind of bides their time
buys their time buys their time and
eventually Trump is the nominee
you know folks men and women are
different this is it shouldn't be a
brave thing to say this shouldn't be
social but men and women are different
not just physically but at a deeper
level as well and ironically the more
the libs try to erase those differences
the more pronounced the differences
become
holding on to those sorts of facts and
understanding them is essential that's
at the heart of Dennis prager's new
episode of prageru Masters program in
this series Dennis is sharing 40 years
worth of hard-earned wisdom as he
explores all kinds of topics how to be a
good person hurdles to happiness the
case for marriage but this new episode
is extremely important because the more
men and women understand each other the
more they will be able to accept and
appreciate their unique differences very
fun episode you don't want to miss it
head on over to dailywordplus.com become
a member and watch Prager use master's
program today my favorite comment
yesterday is from Alec man's
t629 who says
don't underestimate how sexy the sex
robots will be best Michael Knowles
quote ever thank you I I hope that goes
into some compendium of all of my
greatest bits of wisdom do not
underestimate how sexy the sex robots
will be it's very easy for us
conservatives to mock the idea of all
this but
even Beyond sex robots and sex stuff
generally which is the sauciest and most
titillating which is why it dominates
the conversation but even beyond that
just think about the other pleasures of
the modern world the food
the relaxation the Leisure the Comfort
the clothing even the all of it
it's all really nice and tempting
and then you think about even food
that's bad for you the food in this
model is so cheap it's so sweet it's so
fatty and greasy and nice and juicy and
tasty it's very hard to resist and then
we can become big fat slobs and we eat
all the chemicals that turn the freaking
frogs gay and you know these things
happen
because it's hard to resist temptation
and if you're sometimes conservatives we
talk about
Temptation and the abstract we say oh
we're everyone's falling into the
Temptations of decadent liberal society
and we shouldn't do that be it on Pride
be it on gluttony be it on wrath be it
on weird sex stuff be it on sloth you
know but
there's a reason that people fall into
temptation temptation is tempting
speaking of
Vice and sin and accusations about all
that stuff
and speaking about the primaries this
time the Democrat primary Korean
Champion spokesman for President Joe
Biden has responded to Bobby Kennedy's
viral clip you remember we played it on
the show a couple days ago in the clip
Bobby Kennedy was being recorded at what
seemed to be a semi-private dinner where
he said
that there's a real concern now about
ethnically targeted bio weapons and
there's one theory about covid which is
that kovid targets certain ethnicities
more than others and so it's covet is
harsher on white people and black people
and it's less harsh for East Asians and
Ashkenazi Jews and so that's and no one
really knows why that is but but
there is the scientific theory out there
that's what he said
as a result of saying that he's been
called an anti-semite he hasn't been
called synophobic quite as much he's
called an anti-semite a racist more
broadly a maniac a kook an evil vile
Nazi person and the spokesman for the
president has called him vile
the claims made on that tape is false it
is vile and uh they put our they put our
fellow Americans in danger if you think
about uh the the racist and anti-semitic
uh conspiracy theories that come out of
of saying those types of things it's a
it's an attack on our fellow citizens
our fellow Americans and so it is
important that we essentially speak out
uh when we hear those claims made more
broadly okay notice how vaguely she's
speaking right here she's speaking
vaguely because what she's saying is not
true
she is saying that what Bobby Kennedy
said is not true and it's vile and it's
anti-semitic and it's racist and it's
terrible
what did Bobby Kennedy say Bobby Kennedy
said there is a concern about
ethnically targeted by weapons that's
true that's been in scientific journals
and in popular magazines and newspapers
for years now
that there is a concern that governments
are developing these sorts of things
that claim true what's the next claim
Bobby Kennedy said there is a theory
that kovid targets some ethnicities over
other ethnicities
that is also indisputably true what he's
referring to is a scientific paper
published couple of years ago by a real
medical journal by real scientific
journal that said that because of some
particular aspect of ace2 receptors and
how that relates to the covid virus
white people and black people are more
susceptible to the virus than East
Asians and Ashkenazi Jews that just is
true
that's it and if Bobby Kennedy had said
the Chinese and the Jews are ganging up
to uh craft a bio weapon to take out all
the black people
there would not be evidence of that that
would not that I guess then Karine
jumpier could go off on her rent but in
terms of what Bobby Kennedy actually
said on that video
the claims he made were relatively
modest and indisputably true we went
through the scientific paper on on the
show the other day
but it has to be vile it has to be awful
and terrible and racist and okay why is
the White House saying that well because
Bobby Kennedy's pulling 19 20 right now
out of the Democrat primary field almost
certainly Biden will still walk away
with the nomination but it's a threat
and so it's not unusual to have a
political opponent smear
the the other politician in order to
gain electoral Advantage what's even
crazier though
is the Bobby Kennedy's sister Carrie
Kennedy
just came out and said basically the
same thing Carrie Kennedy
said quote I strongly all caps because
she learned how to tweet from Trump I
strongly condemn my brother's deplorable
and untruthful remarks last week about
kova being engineered for ethnic
targeting again just to point out here
you might say the scientific study that
Bobby Kennedy was referring to is not an
accurate scientific study I don't know
what the hell do I know about scientific
studies what do I know about ace2
receptors I'm just but you cannot say
that what Bobby Kennedy said was untrue
in that he merely observed that there is
such a scientific study that was
published in a scientific journal
you how can you say that that is not
true and why is it deplorable why is it
deplorable I thought we were supposed to
follow the science
yeah how is it deplorable to bring up a
scientific study even if maybe the
scientific study isn't true I just don't
know I haven't seen any evidence and
it's not true by the way now there are
other scientific studies that raise
questions about the meaning of that
scientific study we went through those
on the show the other day as well but
how could you say that
it I hate to defend Bobby Kennedy I know
some people on the right really love
Bobby Kennedy now because he's skeptical
of the vaccines and we were all rightly
quite skeptical of the coveted vaccine
but
Bobby Kennedy is a liberal Democrat I'm
not I'm not like campaigning for Bobby
Kennedy some people say well you know if
the Kennedys were around today they
would be Republicans that's not true you
know we know that's not true because the
Kennedys are around today and they're
and they're Democrats and they're Libs
and they campaign and all sorts of lib
issues and they're totally bought into
the climate change nonsense you know
world is going to end agenda and they're
broadly speaking pro-abortion and
they're broadly speaking in favor of
redefining marriage and they're broadly
speaking in favor of all the other sorts
of silly lib policies taking away our
guns all the rest of it so I'm not
please don't sign me up to be the
campaign manager for Bobby Kennedy or
any other Kennedy or any other Democrat
but I gotta call it like I sees it I
gotta I've gotta
be truthful here
and the truth is in in the modest claims
that Bobby Kennedy made
he didn't say anything that was wrong
and Karine Jean-Pierre White House Press
Secretary and Bobby Kennedy's sister
activist liberal Democrats
they are saying things that are wrong as
they usually do what's the takeaway here
the takeaway here is that for liberals
no bond supersedes political convenience
no bond certainly not the family they've
spent 100 years trying to destroy the
family
and they've had great success doing that
so Carrie Kennedy can throw her brother
under the bus easily
a Biden can throw Kennedy under the bus
easily even a Kennedy even this is the
first family of democrat politics these
days
they can do it
for the Liberals no bond supersedes it
this is why you always see the Liberals
put out these these these stupid
advertisements and videos before
Thanksgiving to say here's how you know
you scream at your Republican Uncle at
Thanksgiving hey you wanna have a good
Thanksgiving here's how you can you can
ruin dinner by talking about health care
or
some fashionable ideology that we're not
allowed to talk about on big Tech ER
here's a here's how you can bring up
immigration at the Christmas table and
ruin Thanksgiving why do they say all
that because they don't think Family
Matters all that much I disagree with
much of my family on all sorts of issues
but when I go to a family gathering I
don't I'm not there to win some stupid
partisan political debate I'm not there
to convince them to vote for some
Republican candidate I'm there to be
with my family and do family stuff
because I like because that's really
important
and as a practical matter for much of my
life that's much more important than
whatever political issue du jour there
is for the libs they don't believe that
the libs want you to stop talking once
you scream at your Republican Uncle at
Thanksgiving they want you to stop
talking to him they want you to
ostracize him they don't want you to
talk to or hang out with your parents
they don't want you to be really close
with your husband or your wife and be in
an indissoluble Bond that's the basic
building block of society they want you
to be a completely atomized individual
strong individual with no particular
ties to anyone other than to the regime
today's woke Wednesday baby
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code knowleskin wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]